hey guys it's Justine and today we are
unboxing me brand new Google pixel 3 XL
I've actually been well at the times me
posting this video I've been using this
for about I guess a few weeks at this
point but today you're gonna be
witnessing the unboxing of said phone
does it make sense does it the magic of
editing also got the pixel stand which I
am already in love with and a nice
little case let's get started so this is
the clearly white version there's two
other colors as well the pink well it's
called not pink I think it's probably my
favorite you know a huge fan of like
rose gold and pink blush tones so uh
it's beautiful but Google sent me this
one to check out
oh it has a really really nice feel so
because I just have wireless charging
obviously is a glass back so you can see
it has a kind of a duotone glass this
has like a frosted glass this is a shiny
glass got your camera a flash and a
perfectly placed fingerprint sensor USBC
cable USB a 2 USB C dongle another
dongle USB C 2 a 3.5 millimeter jack
headphones look at these so that's
everything that came in the box now it's
time to boot this thing up oh gosh I
can't get over the coloured power
buttons this is something that I really
love that Google does it's you wow that
notch is big so you squeeze the edges
which is kind of cool to get your
assistant that's hard squeeze I need to
lighten it up
I guess we're set up this is quicker
than I thought not freaking City it's
it's definitely there I mean it doesn't
really bother me that much mostly
because I am so used to I guess my
iPhone and then the notes like all the
phones that I've been using it's just
sort of the thing that is there so here
you can see the notch size differences
it's not as long but it is a lot taller
what I am so excited to test out is the
photos because this does have so I guess
I can show you here so there you are
but that's the wide angle and it goes
all the way in so look at this can you
see that that's so cool the wide angle
is so wide I look forward to testing
this out a little bit more but now we
should probably finish up unboxing this
and check out this case and you know
stands we can charge this thing up
whoa I love all of Google's accent
colors for the charging brick get
another USBC cable think google loves
USB see especially these sleek white
tables so this stand will act as a 10
watt charger for your pixel but it will
also charge any other Qi compatible
devices at five watts so that means yes
it will charge your iPhone if you choose
to do so just a little bit slower this
is a nice case this is a very nice case
and it's got the mint green on soft I
love with this case so much I do wish
this had a facial recognition though
because I'm so used to that look how
these looks those are two very nice
complementary colors hmm I agree well I
think I've opened everything so now I
guess we can go outside and that's the
thing out looks some photos before we
get into this video I just from the same
sorry you guys noticed this and some of
my photos and videos that I posted in
social I cracked my pixel I'm interested
to see some drop tests to see how
durable this is because I dropped this
with a case on it and I don't know it
must have just fell into the most
perfect way for this to happen but it
did and it happened right after I
unboxed it like I actually opened it
went and I was going to do some photo
tests and it just fell and I just my
heart it's just saying I think one of
the things that these cases need to do
is have a little bit higher of a lip -
if you can see on some of these iPhone
cases which are just the regular Apple
ones they go a little bit higher up now
it is a very very slight difference but
that little slight difference makes all
the difference so when you're dropping
this thing face down any little bit of
support around those edges is going to
help but it's still working and all
things considered it wasn't really that
bad I know you're probably gonna say
classic Justine you're super
irresponsible I might be the good news
is it didn't affect my phone in any way
whatsoever so anyway moving on now that
the pixel is unboxed we have magically
been transported to Hawaii and I've been
taking a ton of photos on the pixel 3
and on the iPhone and I've been sharing
them
it is such a polarizing reaction
watching you guys react to the photos
that I post you guys are fighting with
each other saying that you love the
photo because it was shot on an iPhone
or hating it because of a shot on the
iPhone or you're debating that no that
was it shot on iphone that was actually
shot on a pixel and I'm telling you no
it was actually shot on an iPhone or the
other way around I'm arguing with you
telling you that it was shot on a pixel
but you guys think it's shot of an
iPhone and I feel like that almost is
kind of a good thing because the
technology is getting so good in every
device that we get that it's hard to
tell what its job with there are very
small differences that sometimes you're
able to tell which was shot on which and
just by my I guess testing it out in the
past week I will say that the pixel
definitely wins in low-light situations
so a lot of photos that I've taken and
compared them to the iPhone when it's a
little bit darker out they do tend to
let in a lot more light and they do look
a little bit more crisp so I definitely
feel like that is one of the places that
the pixel has excelled at something that
gets me super fired up though is after
using this thing for like the past week
there's absolutely no way that this is
accurate like this is so far from the
truth
most of the photos that you take on the
pixel are way darker than the photos
that they take on the iPhone the smart
HDR brings out the shadows so much in
the iPhone that it sometimes does have
that over-processed looked so I don't
know where they got this photo at
because this is just absurd almost every
time that I took a picture with the
pixel and comparing it to the iPhone the
pixel was significantly darker but
moving on the bottom line is that a lot
of people have differing opinions and
that's what makes art and photography so
incredible everyone has different tastes
and some people may see a painting or a
photo and say I don't like that whereas
somebody else is just beyond impressed
and it could be their most favorite
thing ever so with that in mind while
you're watching this video and maybe
even carrying on with the rest of your
day or the rest of your week or the
month or the rest of your life just
because someone doesn't like something
that you like you don't have to
criticize them for it because guess what
they probably don't like what you like
which is obvious because if you don't
like what they like then they don't like
what you like so just be kind but let's
jump into one of the things that I have
really really been enjoying the most
about the pixel 3 is the wide-angle
selfie the selfie camera on the iPhone
here's a little comparison you can see
that there is no wide-angle option on
the ice
I do hope that that is something that
they plan to integrate in the future
because it would be incredible so here's
some of the wide-angle selfies that I
took with my sister who was so confused
because I had both of my phone it's kind
of connected together taking the same
photos and she's like wait which one do
I look at but you can tell you can get
so much more in the frame it is a little
bit distorted around the edges but it's
not as bad as some wide-angle lenses
that I've seen before the wide-angle
selfie mode also carries over to video
which is incredible the only gripe that
I have is the audio on the pixel is not
as good as that of the iPhone it's not
terrible it's just definitely not as
good so on the back camera on the pixel
it only shoots up to 4k 30 frames
whereas the iPhone does 4k 60 I
definitely thought that the pixel would
have a little bit higher frame rate so
taking that into consideration here is
some test footage from both of the back
cameras from both of the phones
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes I just zoomed as much as I
could in Brienne how cool do I look so
one of the things that I do like about
the front-facing camera here on the pics
so one of the trends of the past couple
of years has been Gimbels so a gimbal is
something that used to stabilize your
phone or your camera but the latest
trend is how do you get those gimbal
like shots without actually using a
gimbal I did a review recently of the
GoPro Hero 7 and the stabilization on
that thing is so amazing the pixel three
uses something that Google is calling
fused video stabilization so the
stabilization only works on the back
camera and if you're shooting in 1080p
you will actually get a much better
stabilized shot so whatever the fused
video stabilization is it probably
shoots the video in 4k and then
downgrades at 1080p and because of a
shot in 4k it has so much more data to
work with to digitally stabilize that
video now I tested the pixel three
against the iPhone 10s but I also tested
the pixel three against the hero seven
so here are seven like I said before is
it just blew my mind and how great it
wasn't stabilizing so it will be
interesting to see those two
side-by-side the first up let's see what
the stabilization is like on the pixel 3
compared to the iPhone
[Applause]
[Music]
let's test out the pixel three a verse V
GoPro Hero seven running to catch up to
them again
[Music]
I did oh my gosh no my PO just fell out
of my pocket back to my first grown
so both phones obviously have slo-mo
mode the pixels shoots at 240 frames a
second at 720p whereas the iPhone shoots
1080p 240 frames a second what a
beautiful segue into a slow mode
demonstration
[Music]
one of the interesting things is the
pixel still only has one camera whereas
the iPhone tennis has two so this has it
regular lens and a telephoto lens
so with that telephoto lens that allows
the iPhone 10s to do portrait mode
photos and this also does portrait mode
photos but it uses machine learning to
try to figure out what should be blurred
and what shouldn't so it is super
impressive what this can do with just
one lens it will do portrait mode on the
front and the back all in all I was
pretty impressed with some of the
portrait mode photos that the pixel took
it really is such a difficult thing
because there are so many variables when
you're taking these photos especially
because I have blonde hair and a lot of
these photos were taken sort of in very
windy situations it was really difficult
for both of these phones to try to
figure out what should be in focus and
what shouldn't so we've been talking a
lot about photos and video because
that's one of the main things I feel
like most people use their phones for
other than making phone calls I guess or
texting which I do a lot of that but
phone calls not so much this is leading
me into something called call assist
which I'm super fascinated by using the
Google assistant if somebody calls you
don't want to talk to them you can send
it to your assistant your assistant will
then say hey what's up this isn't a real
person I'm not real but talk to me
anyway hello I'm trying to talk to
Justine but I gotta click something ok
so this is me taking an action I want to
talk to Justine do you need to get a
hold of them urgently yes it is very
important that I speak to do see I think
that you should subscribe to my youtube
channel that says I think you should
describe sweaty two channels oh my gosh
what is happening your sis it will
transcribe in real time what that person
is saying so if you decide that hey I
want to take this call you can click
answer and you can then take it or you
can just let your assistant keep
chatting with them google lens is also
pretty cool you can copy and paste text
you can search directly with inside of
your camera you just do a one long hold
press and as you hover your camera over
top of things it's automatically doing
searches you can copy dates you can copy
times you can add things to your
calendar you can also shop directly from
your camera which is super dangerous
let's try it here on the smart
it knew that this were smart water we'll
try a plan to identify her it showed me
the freaking plant it's called cron tonk
Ron Don's what are you oh boy oh my gosh
it's the same plant although this one
says it's a California Current on it's
called a Croton I've been reading it
wrong well I think Ron Don sounds way
cooler people are always asking me which
fell in the vase again and honestly I
don't have an answer for that because
all of this stuff is personal opinion
whereas my personal opinion is I love my
iPhone it works for what I need it to do
granted there are some things that I
feel like they could also improve on
I love the pixel three I love the note 9
probably the one Android phone that I
use the most out of this past year was
the one plus six that sandstone white
was so beautiful then after that I went
to the note 9 and being someone who does
review technology and get a chance to
use a lot of these phones it's hard to
say because they are all really great
devices so my best advice is to watch
everyone's videos take bits and pieces
from everyone and go into stores and
actually test them out for yourself it's
great because Best Buy always has all of
the Samsung phones the Apple Store has
all of the iPhones and any other retail
store like 18t or Verizon or D Mobile or
anything you can go in try the phones
test them out and see what works for you
so there just are so many things there's
so many variables what makes you happy
is what should matter so with that it
doesn't have to be applied to just your
phone whatever it is whatever it is that
makes you happy
don't let anyone tell you that that
isn't something that you should like
because they don't know you they aren't
you and they are probably just trying to
bring you down so live your best life
I'm gonna go and edit this video right
now and I am dreading it there's a lot
of photos and a lot of videos but thank
you for watching you can meet at this
bar do subscribe if you'd like I've got
a lot of fun videos coming out from
Hawaii so stay tuned
it's like tech Christmas
[Music]